is it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on psbg on sensor the Israel
Hass Wars claim tens of thousands of
lives and sewn chaos across the Middle
East there's no end in sight so tonight
we've invited two of our most passionate
and polarizing experts back to debate
the big questions how does all this end
what is the future for Palestine and for
Israel can there ever be
peace and since this our final show of
the year we'll review a tumultuous 2023
then the biggest winners and Biggest
Losers of the year and look ahead to a
thoroughly uncensored and unpredictable
2024 live from the news building in
London this is Pier Morgan uncensored
well good evening from London a Merry
Christmas just about anyway it's almost
that special time of year when we argue
about television and fall asleep in
front of it but before we all get to
that place here are just a few of the
moments we argued on the television
making sure absolutely nobody was
falling asleep in front of it I'm asking
who determines you get deter it you get
to deter who gets to deter you to work
out I was coerced into this interview
you weren't coerced into yes I was fine
you want just shout at me that's your
prog your TV your show should herass
stay in power it's the question I'd
rather do it on camera no no no no why
we'll explain why we are not prepared to
apologize to millions of people for
screwing their personal
finances you don't care about the little
guys billions of being murdered and you
don't care why you against nuclear weap
if you're if you're not against res why
you against nucle ask the question I've
done this before this job let me do it
I've been answering your question you
answer mine it's actually not my job to
answer your
questions well Britain managed to keep
the same prime minister for an entire
year which was a modern day record
we crowned a new king first new monarch
in my lifetime and a no spring chicken
and England were crowned winners of the
moral ashes after some despicable
cheating by the Australians Boris
Johnson left politics and entered the
Dustbin of history for now mortgages
rocketed again everyone seemed to be on
strike inflation drained our bank
accounts as sewage drained into the Seas
and it was easier to strike gold than to
find a dentist or book an appointment
with your GP Boris and rishy lost an
awful lot of the text messages this
morning lost Holly and Phil Captain Tom
Mo's family lost a luxury home spa and
just St oil lost just about all public
support and that Rubi Alis kiss became a
sporting crisis Cristiano Ronaldo the
goat followed up his exclusive interview
with me by signing the biggest contract
in the history of sport George Santos
followed up his exclusive interview with
me by signing up for Cameo guess it
doesn't work out for everybody roll
dal's children's book were deemed so
offensive they had to be censored Prince
Harry's book which actually was
offensive got some deci side of the
uncensored reviews including from me and
the Barbie movie bash men with a big
pink assault on the patriarchy making us
all which the Hollywood writers stayed
on strike it's been a big year here on
uncensored
to your favorite nickname that Trump's
given you so far is it Ron Ronda
sanctimonious or meet ball Ron I lost my
mom then I lost my grandson and then I
lost my daughter you stop the camera
please a battle with cancer and I'm
crying now God I'm such a softy the main
bulk of American of the American public
supporters real right but not Democrat
supporters and nor the young ones 18 to
29 do you feel a great loss that you
didn't have the love of your parents you
sound like my wife how do you feel about
potentially testifying in a child that
be watched around the world I'm the only
one that has been telling the truth guns
kill people I think people kill people
you're to resign yes cuz I cannot
continue my work nurses are actually
massively out of pocket because of
inflation I don't think that's a fair
characterization on
[Music]
them well in April we celebrated hitting
a million subscribers on YouTube in
record time it made us the fastest
growing Broadcast News opinion channel
in the world and we're going to need a
bigger cake because in the months that
follow that number has now doubled to
2.3 million and Rising fast I was
humbled well almost that my show won
three major Awards uh most recently uh I
got the broadcast journalist of the year
at the media Freedom Awards and that
meant a lot because that is a
prestigious one and it was on behalf of
my brilliant team here at Piers Morgan
uncensored who have I think displayed
that we are uncensored and we do believe
in freedom of speech and we do believe
in media freedom of speech in particular
but uncensored now has more trophies
officially than Tottenham hoser and
we're not slowing down let's not forget
that there were some Gravely significant
world events this year too they formed a
huge part of our coverage the world was
gripped by the search for the Titan
submersible which ended in tragedy a
mercenary launched a coup against Putin
then found out the hard way what happens
if you do that Ukraine's counter
offensive turned out to be well not that
successful having fought the invading
Russians to a stalemate zsky spent this
year fighting to retain the world's
support in their Battle For Freedom
Hamas terrorists committed the worst
attack on the Jewish people since the
Holocaust forcing Israel into a a brutal
War that's now killing tens of thousands
of innocent people and has no end in
sight and the world said goodbye to many
Legends too Barry Humphries Paul o'
Grady Jeff Beck John mson Lance Ric Len
Goodman Jerry Springer Tina Turner
Trevor Francis Tony Bennett Michael
Parkinson Bobby charton Matthew Perry
Terry venables Henry Kissinger Shane
mcgaan shano Connor Benjamin Zephaniah
and there were many more on a brighter
note scientists warned that AI would
take all our jobs and then take over the
world but for now we're still here and I
predict we'll still be here next year
too bigger better and even more unsensed
speaking of which here's what I
predicted would happen in
2023 in 2023 Putin will try and fail in
my estimation to bully Ukraine and the
West into submission Prince Harry will
once again trash his family in his
attention seeking woe is me Memoir Joe
Biden and and Donald Trump with their
combined 156 years will hopefully decide
to put their country before further runs
for the White House meanwhile Florida
Governor Ronald De santis will urge
Republicans to surely dump Trump and run
with him there'll be a Rugby World Cup
Eurovision unfortunately returns this
time to the UK for the first time since
1998 Arsenal will absolutely definitely
win their first premier league title
since 2004
possibly well I was nearly right we
should have won the league and we will
win the League this season you can take
it to the bank and play this back next
year uh well next year more people will
go to the polls in any time in human
history in America Donald Trump looks
likely to either be president or in
prison or possibly both at the same time
sadly I see no chance of Peace in
Ukraine Putin will dig in until the US
election and hope that his friend Trump
wins Israel will be forced into a
ceasefire eventually but the Fallout
from this war will continue to Royal the
the region with grave and unexpected
consequences throughout the world in
Britain labor are heading it looks like
to inexorable success in the election
but it won't be as comfortable I suspect
as everybody seems to think the economy
recovers maybe Richie has a chance and
Arsenal as I said will win their first
premier league title since 2004 which
ironically was when I got fired as
editor of the Daily Mirror let's hope
that history doesn't repeat itself if we
do it again I stuck into all this with
my my Christmas party pack we're calling
them this year but first uh we thought
that we'd end the year with a debate
between Douglas Murray and Jen Yuga who
been two of our most passionate and
polarizing experts on the Israel Hamas
War they bitterly opposing views they
have big brains with big answers to the
big questions on this war they've never
gone head-to-head before tonight they do
on uncens
[Music]
that's
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online onun
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come for Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan you have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out
vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man mous man
mous man he should be easy enough to
catch this guy shouldn't he I mean he's
got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resolve yes cuz I cannot
continue my work when I say I am God I'm
not joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you prepar to call h a terror group is
it possible to have a rational I've
asked you two questions should aass stay
in power and are they a terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love pury we can agree on
that
[Music]
welcome back to un s Douglas Murray and
Jen Yuga are on bitterly opposing sides
of a debate on Israel's war in Gaza
Millions have watched them passionately
articulate their cases on this show but
never together so tonight on our final
show of the year we've invited these two
big brains to debate the big outstanding
questions on this conflict how does the
war end will Israel face repercussions
for the scale of its response to October
the 7th has it committed war crimes what
is the future if any for Hamas for Gaza
and for the prospects of a true
Palestinian State most importantly how
do we get to peace well I'm now joined
by the author of the war on the West
Douglas Murray and by Young Turks
founder and Democratic presidential
Challenger Jen Yugo welcome to both of
you so I've I've interviewed you both a
lot in this War uh but not together and
Jen I know you felt the other night when
you were debating other people didn't
really get into a debate and I think
that's fair enough uh and what I'd like
to today really is to be almost a
referee if you like between you two to
articulate your views and to see if we
can reach any points of consensus um so
in that spirit let me start with you
Douglas um I think you're back in Israel
uh is that
right yes I'm in Israel tonight yeah
today it was a sea of other stories have
come out in the last few days which have
been concerning I think for anyone who
like me believes that Israel has not
just a moral duty to defend itself but
has a fundamental right to do so after
what happened October the 7th and I said
that clearly from the start it's always
been for me the issue of of
proportionality and it seems that in the
last few days there have been a number
of incidents which really question
whether whether Israel is being precise
as it says it is or or indiscriminate
and I would cite the the killing of the
three hostages I would cite the killing
of the two women outside the Catholic
church I would cite the president of the
United States saying that they're using
indiscriminate bombing uh and so on do
you Douglas notwithstanding your Full
Throttle support of Israel does anything
that's been happening make you think
Israel needs to execute this war
differently
no and I think that most of the people
who think they know how to execute this
War uh have never executed a war indeed
most people who think they know how the
IDF should be running this conflict have
never been near a conflict I'm in Israel
tonight I was in Gaza again yesterday um
and the examples that you give by the
way peers I don't see why they show any
need to prosecute the war itself
differently I mean they just to take one
of them the first example you give the
absolutely tragic awful um um shooting
of these three hostages as they were
coming out but you know the some of the
spin that's been put on that in the
world apart from the Glee of course that
Israel's enemies can't help expressing
um some of the spin on that is is almost
as if it shows the IDF is sort of so
brutal that it even kills Hamas hostages
who are Israeli I just think this is
another example of the international
media and others just having this
astounding lack of empathy for the
Israeli people can you imagine what it
was like for those soldiers who were in
Gaza knowing that at any point there
were snipers there are there were uh
booby traps everywhere um people coming
out of tunnels that they've built at
British and American taxpayer expenses
and attacking them can you imagine what
it was like for the soldiers who in that
terrible moment made the lifechanging
mistake of shooting three people who
turned out to be Hamas hostages why
would on that on that why would they
shoot anyone who who was shirtless and
waving an SOS flag I mean why would
whoever they were whether they Israeli
hostages or whether they thought they
were Palestinians why would anyone shoot
anyone who comes out like that that's my
point that'll that that'll be a matter
for the inquiry into it but uh you know
look it's hardly as if they'd have
wanted to have done that what this
demonstrates is in this incredibly close
conflict in a heavily built up area
people come coming out from all sides
firing shooting detonating uh people
make mistakes of course they do that's
just a human reality of War horrible as
it is I don't think it shows in any way
that Israel is Prosecuting this war
wrongly as for the main issue of the war
the main issue of the war is to destroy
Hamas no Israeli of left or right or
Center believes anymore after October
7th they can live beside Hamas Hamas has
been given the statelet of Gaza it was
given it in 20 2006 voted in then killed
their fellow Palestinians in a coup
killed Fatar Rivals and they've run the
Gaza for almost 18 years now and they've
produced a new gener generation of
people whose main aim in life it seems
according to their text books and their
classes is to regard Jews as enemies who
should be killed this is just an
unbelievable waste a waste of life on
every side but apart from anything else
a waste of those Palestinian lives of
children who grew up under hamas's rule
if you can call it that who have been
indoctrinated into becoming sociopaths
by a psychopathic Terror organization
Hamas all right Jen you've been
listening to that um is there anything
that Douglas said that you agree
with no nothing not even about the way
Hamas has has presided over Gaza in the
last 18 years yeah so that's a weapon of
mass distraction uh it it's Israel doing
genocide on the Palestinians right now
and uh there's IDF soldiers singing and
and in video that the IDF has confirmed
about how they're going to wipe out the
seed of AMC that is a a verse in the old
Hebrew Bible that talks about
Exterminating amalec so they're talking
about genocide against Palestinians uh
Benjamin Netanyahu has also talked about
uh wiping out amalec these are open
calls for genocide what I find stunning
he you know Douglas mentioned stunning
lack of empathy there's 20,000 dead
people in Palestine right now in Gaza uh
over 8,000 of them are children when 36
Israeli children were killed by Hamas
the world cried out and I was
brokenhearted over it 36 poor kids dead
in Israel now there's over
8,000 dead kids in Gaza you want to talk
about a stunning lack of empathy 6,4 400
women slaughtered in Gaza you want to
talk about terrorism they're dropping
unguided bombs 2,000 pound bombs every
one of those bombs is an act of
terrorism and the stunning lack of
empathy towards Palestinian lives is
disgusting but I want to be clear it is
not shared by all Israelis the dad of
one of the hostages who was killed went
on Israeli television and said stop
killing them and he didn't mean the
hostages he meant the Palestinians all
right J let me just jump in but before I
go back to Douglas for respons let me
reply to that P yeah I I will let you
reply to that on this issue of genocide
do you accept though that hamas's whole
raise on De when it comes to Israel is
genocide they want to eradicate Israel
and kill as many Jews as they can I
they've made no secret of
this yeah so uh this is really important
so I have no sympathy for Hamas so I'm
not interested in defending Hamas I
think that's nothing but a distraction
because right now they're not fighting
Hamas they're just killing Palestinian
they also killing Hamas terrorists they
are they're killing thousands of them
barely no no wait a minute barely but
let's go to the your main point okay so
the main point is well Hamas threatens X
Y and Z and has killed 1,200 people on
October 7th so that is why we have to
all worry about what Hamas might might
might might
do hold on hold on let me finish the
point let me finish the point let me
finish the point what they might might
might do if they had infinite power the
kind of power that Israel has meanwhile
Israel is actually doing the genocide is
actually preventing a Palestinian State
and saying you are not allowed to exist
and if you dare try to exist we'll kill
of your children and women all right
Douglas respond to
that several things first of all anyone
who uses the term genocide in this
context simply doesn't know what they're
talking about or is a malevolent actor
uh I don't know if Mr weer has traveled
at all in his life how far he's traveled
how many conflicts he's seen but I'd
have guessed none and you clearly know
nothing about this particular conflict
and you've obviously seen none of it um
the genocide that you describe is such a
smear and a liable against the Jewish
state if Israel wanted to commit
genocide I'm sure it could but ites
doesn't it doesn't remotely want to and
people like you and other Pro
Palestinian propagandists have spent
years claiming that Israel is committing
genocide in the Gaza by the way the
weirdest thing about this claim is that
the population of the Gaza has grown by
a million in the last 15 or so years so
if Israel was trying to carry out a
genocide it's either the worst
perpetrator of genocide ever or uniquely
poor at performing that task none of the
stats support that ridiculous claim it's
such a weird smear and a liel of of
Israel secondly of course you've just
rattled off hamas's figures as every one
of your kind always does thirdly you
said that the world cried World cried
you said you said the people like you
who cover for the Palestinian extremists
thirdly you said that the world cried
out for the 36 Israeli dead children no
they didn't and you know that very well
you know that very well if you put up a
poster to a missing dog in any Western
City that poster stays up in city after
city in America posters of abducted
Jewish children including a 10-month-old
baby were put up and were ripped down by
people who have been indoctrinated into
hate of Jews nobody would rip down the
poster of a missing dog but from Dublin
to Berkeley they ripped down posters of
abducted Jewish children so no I don't
think there was very let put Let me let
me let me make two other very quick
points firstly you said what Hamas might
do as if it was some kind of
hypothetical Hamas showed what they do
what they want to do it showed it on
October the 7th and its leadership as
I'm sure you very well know said that
they would like to repeat that again and
again until they have got rid of every
Jew so I don't know I would trust
hamas's word on that rather than your
interpretation of what you think they
mean when they say that and your and
your generous interpretation of what you
think that means and finally as for
preventing a Palestinian state it is
nonsense that the Israelis have
prevented a Palestinian State they gave
the gazans a Palestinian state in 2005
they gave them a Palestinian state in
2005 when every Jewish person was ripped
from their homes in the Gaza by IDF
soldiers and the Palestinian people were
given a state and what did they do they
voted in Hamas who then killed their
fellow Palestinians never had another
election and used all the billions of
dollars of taxpayer funds from the US UK
and Europe to build Terror tunnels and
to enrich themselves so they could live
the life of luxury and Qatar again and
again the reason there is not a
Palestinian state is because the
Palestinian leadership doesn't want one
didn't want one in 1947 it preferred war
and it doesn't want one now dougas let
me put one point to you raised by Queen
Rony of of Jordan in a new piece for I
think it was the Washington Post uh in
just over two months she said Israel's
turned Gaza into a hellscape at least
8,000 children have died more than the
death tolls of Pearl Harbor September
the 11th and hurcan Katrina combined
these are gigantic and horrendous
numbers of children being killed do you
not have any quams about the number of
children being killed I mean does it not
suggest that Israel I want to hear I
want to qu I want to hear Queen Ria
talking about this as much as I want to
hear Queen Camila or Megan Markle I mean
it's pathetic Queen Ria is holding on to
her own posess position in Jordan uh the
only piece of advice she has for anyone
is how to marry a king uh Queen Ria
herself is just playing a very nasty
political game if she cared at all and I
would pose this to all the states in the
region if Jordan cared at all for the
Palestinian people they would take them
in they would take them in they don't
want them the Egyptian wanted them they
take them in but they don't you know why
because every country that takes in the
Palestinians gets Terror it happened in
Egypt it happened in Jordan it happened
in Syria it happened in Lebanon it
happened in Tunisia on and on that's why
these people don't really care about
their fellow Muslims they just care
about hating Jews all right J your
response yeah so you asked if he cared
about 8,000 dead babies and his answer
was no uh Queen ra bothers me so uh
Complete non-answer because he doesn't
care he doesn't think that Palestinians
lives are worth anything he just called
them all terrorist nice you can put that
this is what they always do so hold on I
let you talk for a long time so why
don't you shut up for a second so uh
we've got all of these dead babies we've
got all of these dead babies that this
monster doesn't care about he says keep
bombing them a Former Intelligence
officer said in the Israeli press
they're using AI in a program called
gospel where he said it's B basically a
mass assassination Factory and we could
all see it with our own eyes and you can
do all the propaganda you want No One
Believes your nonsense we see all the
dead women we see all the dead children
now Israel has killed 20 times the
number of civilians that Hamas killed so
would I want Hamas in charge of Israel
never never I don't trust them and I
don't believe that they would be benign
so all of this propaga about oh like oh
people don't mind Hamas no we mind Hamas
we mind we terribly what happened on
October 7th and I'm now showing you
different Israelis that have said that
it's a problem and I S I want peace and
security for both Israel and Palestine
and this does not get Israel any peace
or security but when you ask the other
side do you mind tens of thousands of
civilians that have been murdered
incinerated alive body parts picked out
of rubble little babies killed over and
over again in what is the even the
Israeli Prime Minister is referring to
asak meaning an extermination of the
Palestinian people and I must clarify
the difference between a genocide and a
holocaust a genocide is when you target
a specific people and kill a lot of
civilians serban where 6,000 people were
killed was considered a genocide so it
is it doesn't mean you try to murder
every single person in
that that is a holocaust
rep one second one second before before
I go to Douglas Jen one question you
want to get rid of Hamas too as does
Douglas as do I if you don't do it the
way that Israel is currently doing it
given that they live amongst the
population how else do you do
it yeah there's an excellent way to do
it and there's the right way to do it so
let me explain so War this guy talks
about oh I love War I go to all the
conflict zones so by watching it and
rooting on for more death I know
something about conflict you know
nothing so here's what reality is war
gets you more war but peace actually
works so when Israel did a peace deal
with Egypt not only were the Egyptians
safe but the Israelis became safer that
peace deal has held for decade after
decade so how do you do a peace deal in
this case what you do is you make a you
do the two-state solution now and you do
it with the Palestinian Authority in the
West Bank and if you then have a
Palestinian State the Palestinian
Authority would have the credibility to
drive out Hamas from Gaza that is a
realistic plan for both peace security
for Israel and the Palestinians and
driving out Hamas the idea that you're
going to kill
20,000 200,000 more civilians in Gaza
and it's going to drive out let Doug let
dougas respond to that first of
all first of all I mean your other guest
I mean I don't know what kind of a
creature he is he's a kind of low-grade
Thug as far as I can see he's listened
to nothing I've said yeah yeah I because
I'm I'll tell you I'll tell you no it's
not that at all it's not that at all I
just think that you're very I think
you're just a very low rent racist but
anyway let me just get on to it you say
you say first of all you say I don't
care about the death of Palestinian
children yes I do care I care very
deeply about it but I also know that the
responsibility for their deaths lies on
hamaz which has misgoverned their
society for the last 16 years and now
has been leading the country into being
in a war with Israel so yes it's on
Hamas this as for seeing Wars by the way
I just mentioned about seeing Wars
because as far as I can see you're very
ill traveled as well as rather ill
lettered and Ill spoken and I mention
that I cover Wars and go to Wars because
I happen to think myself that it's worth
seeing things with your own eyes
including things that you don't
particularly like but you report the
truth I don't know if you ever even
leave your own bedroom and I can tell
already that you don't because you've
already said something that demonstrates
you know nothing about this conflict you
have just demonstrated it in the
following terms you said that this is
why we need to push for a two-state
solution and give legitimacy to the
Palestinian Authority I'll tell you
something you don't know because I guess
you spent no time in the West Bank have
you I'll tell you something you probably
don't know the Palestinian Authority fat
celebrated the 7th of October massacres
I'll give you another fact which
demonstrates you know nothing about this
and clearly haven't ever visited any
Palestinians in the West Bank as I have
if there was an election tomorrow in the
West Bank the reason why there isn't one
is because if there was an election
tomorrow in the West Bank Hamas would
win so your idea of a two-state solution
I'm afraid you are so out of date and
you really should leave your bedroom
because in this region nobody thinks
that there is a two-state solution on
the table because there is not a viable
negotiating partner but I just want to
make one other main point you have gone
on and on tonight throwing accusations
out against the Jewish State against me
it's a sort of thing you do I know
you're a sort of sort of online pugilist
and think you can run for office and
good luck with that but I'd just like to
point out that you only really get
animated if the Jews are involved and I
can tell that for the following reason I
mean your surname is weager isn't it 1
million weager Muslims in China have
been put in concentration camps in the
last decade and PE you know people of
your ilk never really care about that do
you because it's not the Jews doing it
it's a Chinese Communist party at the
moment 1 million p Pak one million
people who are from Pak who are in
Pakistan at the moment who are your
fellow Muslims and who happen to be
Afghan and I don't think you care about
them do you 1 million Afghans are
currently being forcibly deported from
Pakistan to Afghanistan you don't care
about that you're not riled up about
that you're not riled up about what the
junga weed are currently doing in Sudan
where thousands and thousands of people
are being attacked by the by the the
islamist militia there you don't care
about any of that you get exercised and
you rile up what little base you have of
Mal contents because you're riled up
when the Jews do anything it's perfectly
obvious okay Jen your response yeah okay
first of all uh my last name is yuger
we're named after the weager Turks in
China and have we talked about that on
spoken up then yes yes I we've talked
about it endlessly but you don't know
that and you don't watch the show watch
show nobody does watch your show yeah
well okay again you're interrupting me
when I was kind enough to let you do go
on with your mad ramblings so it how
nobody watches the show we have five
billion views a year uh I don't know
what piddling outfit you're on or what
little substack or whatever the hell you
write on so the reason we're incredibly
popular we fight for shut up we fight
for all innocent civilians so yes we've
covered all of those conflicts yes I'm
against fundamentalist Islam no question
about it I'm against Fundamentalist
religions of all kind in terms of
uh every right-wing supporter of Israel
there only tactic is hey don't look at
the 8,000 murdered children don't look
at the 6,400 murdered women don't look
at the fact that all the hospitals in
Northern Gaza have been shut down don't
look at the fact that four out of five
people in Northern Gaza are starving
right now and half the people in
southern Gaza are starving instead
anti-semite anti-semite now I wait a
minute I just told you how much I want
how much I hated what happened on
October 7th what you don't know is I
started The Young Turks with two Jewish
friends and so the whole program is both
Jews and Muslims you know nothing you
know nothing I have Jewish family and
friends why in the world Gods as they go
to Israel I want them to be safe okay so
I have shown empathy for all civilians
throughout everything I have ever done
but all you have is hatred oh he's an
anti-semite kill the Muslims kill the
Palestinians and once we kill them by
the way we'll blame them for it we had
to Israel had to murder all those babies
in Palestine because Hamas made a
steward then why are you listening to
Hamas why are you letting Hamas drive
your agenda well you don't have to kill
those civilians it's a mass
assassination
Factory we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about to today we do it
all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear all favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy and need
to be one human per machine to come and
rectify beats and the clanks and when it
goes roll unexpected item in bagging
area I know are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from a gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
Union Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking for a Liv if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
hand thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve
when I say I am God I'm not joking did
you feel Elvis was controlling I've been
answering your question you answer mine
is actually she not my job to answer
your question are you prepared to call h
a terror group is it possible to have a
rational talk TV it's the only place
where you get the
truth this is talk TV
[Music]
we are what nine weeks into this war
20,000 people according to the Hamas run
health authority but the numbers have
not been questioned by other official
bodies 20,000 people so far have died on
the Palestinian side and it is estimated
from the IDF that they they say they've
killed 7,000 or so Hamas terrorists that
number has not been verified but if you
take that as being accurate that's 20%
of the the estimated number of Hamas
terrorists that exist therefore there's
80% still to be eliminated which at this
rate would take another 8 to 10 months
and would lead to potentially several
hundred thousand civilians being killed
and pretty much all of G are being
obliterated with nowhere for the 2
million he've been displaced to go back
to so my question for you is if this is
the game plan by Israel to finish Hamas
right to theas terrorist what is left
after that they talk about about the day
after the war what does it look like who
runs Gaza where do these people go back
to live in other words what actually
happens if Israel is successful however
long it takes in eliminating
Hamas well first of all I just have have
to add you you quite rightly said it
appears that the figures you gave are
Hamas figures and we do have to treat
them with more than a grain of salt um
as for again uh my counterpart here goes
on about uh the deliberate genocide of
children and and women I mean I know and
this is a sort of thing I I think you do
you sort of claim that there are bombs
being deliberately dropped on children
and old women why would Israel want to
drop bombs deliberately on children or
old women I mean you just again it's
just a shame you don't get out and see
anything um the Israelis do an
incredibly careful campaign before
bombings to try to make sure that
civilians are warned to live leave areas
that are about to be attacked everybody
knows that everybody in the region knows
that it's a shame that that fact hasn't
got to you as it happens the whole
question you raised Pier is a very very
complex one I don't have the answer I
don't believe anyone does have the
answer about the day after uh nobody
wants to rule the Gaza uh the Israelis
used to be in charge of it they left as
I say in 2005 to the last Jew they were
all taken out of their houses Israel
doesn't want to rule the Gaza now who
can rule the Gaza hamaz clearly cannot
because they set it up as a terrorist
statelet can some fat like Authority be
encouraged to take it over possibly
possibly I spoke to one Palestinian
analyst earlier today who said that
actually just as I said earlier that an
election in the West Bank today would
elect Hamas perhaps an election tomorrow
if it was to happen and I'm not sure if
that's going to be a good idea might
even actually elect not hamaz
Palestinians to power but it's a heck of
a risk the reality is that the only
solution to Gaza that anyone can see I
can I can imagine is it it has to be a
solution which involves multiple players
in the region the question of the Gaza
is a very complex question it used to be
ruled by Egypt used to be run by Egypt
can Egypt have a role in my view it has
to have a role can Jordan be involved in
my view yes it has to have a role can
the Gulf States including those who've
been pumping money to hamaz have some
kind of role yes I would hope so it
cannot be Israel's ask alone to deal
with the question of the Gaza it has to
involve multiple players in the region
but there's one kicker to that which is
that none of the Arabs in this region
that I'm sitting in care a jot about the
Palestinians they really do not if they
did for all of their talk they would
have done something they would not have
decided to keep the Palestinians out as
they have in country after Country Queen
Ria can invite the uh gazans into Jordan
she can invite invite the West Bank
Palestinians into Jordan she doesn't
Egypt could open its border with Gaza it
doesn't the Egyptian border with Gaza is
firmer and more closely locked than the
Israeli ones there are gazan workers who
until the atrocities of October the 7th
every day were going through the erets
crossings and others to work in Israel
and to earn a decent living were there
workers going in Daily into Egypt no
because the Egyptians don't want pales
inian in their country so the only
solution is a regional one but I'm
afraid in this region there are very few
people who care about the Palestinians
okay uh Douglas you had the first word
uh Jen I'll give you the last word I
want to preface it by saying that it's
been reported today and this has come
from uh hamas's uh statements apparently
picked up by newspapers in America that
there was a new hostage deal offered
which was that Hamas will asked will you
release the 40 women and children you
still have captive uh in return for a
week-long ceasefire and they apparently
have rejected that so I think that when
we talk about uh behavior on both sides
the mere fact that there are still 40
women and children in the clutches of
Hass and God knows what they're doing to
those poor women um that should be noted
too there are still innocent people
being held in the most appalling
conditions by Hamas and that is also
motivating Israel's response but I'll
give you the last word
yeah so I I wish to God that they would
release those women and and children I
think it's immoral to keep them it's
wrong in every way uh but Israel kills
more than 40 women and children every
single day uh all completely innocent U
look even if you take idf's outlandish
numbers of 7,000 Hamas Fighters killed
that means their kill ratio of civilians
to Fighters is still worse than hamas's
and they have now killed 20 times the
number of civilians that Hamas has
killed so when when Douglas talks about
driving them into Egypt or Jordan that's
just ethnic cleansing they live in Gaza
so if you push them out and they say
well you're all Arabs anyway why don't
you just go live somewhere else in the
region that's the definition of ethnic
cleansing that is outrageous and he says
it with blly with no concern because
Palestinian lives don't matter and you
ask them hey how many Palestinians can
you possibly kill and he never answered
the question so the reality is you
cannot kill your way out of this
conflict the more that they killed the
more what do you think that the
Palestinians are going to feel what
would you feel if your family was
butchered if their heads were crushed by
a bomb that was dropped on a building if
they were lit on fire by the bombs that
were dropped what would you do you'd
fight back the rest of your life and
then they are o permanently occupied now
now Netanyahu says he was proud that he
did prevented a Palestinian State and
that he will continue to prevent a
Palestinian State he is not a partner
for peace or he profits from war his
whole career is about perpetrating War
not just to murder Palestinians but it
keeps Israel unsafe for eternity the
whole point of Israel is to be a safe
haven for oppressed Jews throughout the
world it cannot be a safe haven as long
as you're in prison ing 5 million
Palestinians and saying we are never
ever going to let you go and if you ever
dare oppose us we will kill your women
and children it's disgusting they're not
in prison Ur you again I urge you again
I'd Ur urge you again Chen leave your
bedroom sometime and come to this region
see it for yourself I thought I was
supposed to get the last talking about
bedrooms pales care about the babies you
care about the women Douglas why don't
you admit you don't care about dead
palestin babies dead Palestinian women
cuz you don't mind it Israel Israel
Israel you say right or wrong no matter
how many people they have murdered no
matter how many kids theyed death don't
care because you don't care about human
beings all you want is some sort of
Waring isra State US state
Etc
War I got to say listen I think we
actually had a
very super evil the death of thousands
of people warmongering Jake let's not
descend into this I actually think with
with a few exceptions we had a good
debate there right I understand passions
Run High I think it's a shame whenever I
do these debates when it gets ad homenum
in the way that it has occasionally
tonight but I do think we've also had
some really smart takes from both sides
about what is going on and where we need
to get to I think we can all agree on
one thing we all want to end up with
peace here somehow it's going to be
horrendously difficult we do it's very
complicated that's not true but I do I
don't I don't actually think knowing
both of you as I do I don't believe the
charge that neither of you care is true
I think you do care about all the lies
that are being LA and I think that we we
should start from an acceptance we all
care and then try and be more
constructive but listen I thank you both
for joining me I wish you both a Merry
Christmas I'll see you both no doubt in
the new year and I thank you both I
thank you both for your regular
contributions to the show particularly
since this War started because I I
really appreciate it and I want to hear
both sides and I think you both
articulate your cases extremely
powerfully so thank you both very
much thank you thank you well on S next
I'm joined by my Christmas pack to look
back at 2023 is winners and
losers we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online onun your smart speaker as well
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about sport today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming round the
tracks with sella Bradman she's heading
up one side richy soon at the other the
police have Pro Palestine that is just
not right you swearing off in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million1 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come for Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about the
weirdest plank that we've had in three
years hundreds and hundreds of mice in a
box which he walks into a branch of
McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous he should
be easy enough to catch this guy
shouldn't he I mean he's got house full
of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunak and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast
reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to resol yes cuz I cannot continue
my work when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions are
you you prepar to call h a terror group
is it possible to have a Ral I've asked
you two questions should Hass stay in
power and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
welcome back to un sensor I'm joined by
my Christmas party pack talked to the
contributor Paula Ron Adrian the former
newspaper edor Emily Sheffield and the
So-Cal comedian James Bar welcome to all
three of you right Emily give me your
give me your winner of the Year okay my
winner of the year is kiss starma
because he has bought back yeah wait
he's brought back the lab party I can't
deny he's brought the lab party back
from the brink and he's done done this
amazingly kept 20% ahead in the polls
without saying of anything of any note
power or consequence he still don't know
what he's going to do get that is smart
politics it is smart politics if you
don't need to is smart politics but I
just want to make that clear he has said
nothing of notes nothing of power his
speech boring he looks to me more and
more like a guy who is ready to run the
country yes and I think the public have
been buying into that and so Richie said
I has a lot of work to but I I just got
to bring something up you say that and I
do agree with you but actually his
personal ratings are falling he is
currently at minus 20 or 22% now listen
riss is on minus 70 but Blair a year
ahead of getting to power was plus 16
camon was plus 16 we're not in a
situation and I yes but Cameron was plus
16 so this is where and you said earlier
there might be a bit of a worry when we
get to the next election I don't think
it's all done I don't think it's done
deal either okay James you're winner of
the year um it's Taylor Swift because
she's an I love Taylor Swift queen of
emotions a billionaire it's um I I think
she's a phenomenon at Taylor Swift I
think she's you know you and I disagree
about people like Madonna because I
think that Taylor Swift to me she is a
fantastic role model I've got a
12-year-old girl daughter who loves
Taylor Swift right I love her loving
Taylor Swift in a way I could never ever
wanted to like someone like Madonna yeah
but that's only because Madonna was mean
to you once if Taylor Swift was mean to
you
no she wasn't no I don't mind people
being mean to me I wouldn't have you on
the show Paul your winner of the year
yeah so my winner of the year is Noir
cringle and I know how much you love
inclusivity I know how much you love to
be to represent explain to those who
don't know what it is so Noir cringle is
something that has just been introduced
in the in the UK in England and it's
about a black Father Christmas so uh
anyone can come along and see black
Father Christmas and uh Mrs Claus um
it's something that has been around in
the US for quite a while um and finally
it's come over here because of course
children don't see color they don't see
race it's an adult construct so why why
make a a thing all black then uh why not
why call it noing if they they see why
think about race why not well you're
making you're making what they're doing
is they're having to advertise the fact
that this exists and that's a good thing
and hopefully because hopefully in the
future
need against it personally but you're
selling it as something that makes
children not think about race when in
fact it's having the opposite effect I'm
I'm selling it on the basis that it
involved everybody and and hopefully
we're going to have a drag a drag story
Santa Claus do you think what do you
think I
have Santa basically is drag anyway
those shopping mall Santas are kind of
doing drag aren't they yeah well I'm
going to have a Nelson Mandela tribute
show and they're all going to be white I
mean I'm not sure about that I didn't
think you would be let me explain to you
Mandela never works the other
way you can't change black icons to
white people are we saying that Santa
Claus is white is that a fact is it
because I can tell you as a fact that M
Mandela is of color I can't tell you as
a fact that Santa Claus isn't I actually
have nothing against your choice uh
let's go to The Losers of you Biggest
Loser James um I'm afraid it is rishy
sunak rishy is my biggest loser many
reasons you know it could be because
he's obsessed with boats it could be
because he's obsessed with women whether
they have a penis or not did somebody
say pegging women don't have penises but
my ACT my actual reason for calling him
loser of the year is this terrible
failed Tik Tok transition that he
attempted shout out to bl by the way and
the people of blle um it's just so
embarrassing isn't it it's so
embarrassing I think politicians should
probably stay off Tik Tok Emily you're
you're loser for year uh it's got to be
lisis rubian for that Force kiss I'm
sorry this was like women winning the
World Cups Fantastic Team fantastic we'
seen England lose but a fantastic match
and then this man just comes up and he
grabs her head so sorry it wasn't just a
kiss he grabs either side of the head
and goes like that honestly the fact she
didn't headbutt him or punch him because
I definitely would have done was all
credit to HOSA she was then as far as I
could work out sort of forced to say
that it was like it well let's be honest
they all thought it was funny till they
saw the public reaction was he shouldn't
have done it and then they all turned on
it they they were all dancing on the bus
and chanting and showing videos
we all know what happened there it was
wrong let's not pretend they didn't
think it was funny at the time until
they
realiz always in our society cting the
victim is a better position in our
victimhood societ under Los of year TS
water 16 days worth of uh raw sewage
going into Buck buckinghamshire River
we've got 122 days of an Oxford River
you know I swim in the river temps when
I can and when it's safe to do so so I
mean come on guys what's happening raw
sewage in our rivers and seas yeah thank
you to my pack you've been great this
year I've enjoyed our jostling and I'll
see you in the new year we'll be back on
January the 8th and a little treat for
you uh from the week before I come back
Douglas Murray who you heard earlier he
will be stepping into my shoes for a
week uh from January the 4th I think it
is so tune in to that he'll be doing Pi
Morgan on sens it and from Christmas Day
for a week we have the Christmas
ding-dongs which is what it says on the
Tim it's all the ding-dongs on the show
so you can have a lot of fun through the
festive period with the ding-dongs then
probably some more ding-dongs with
Douglas and then I'll be back for some
massive ding-dongs on January the 8th
that's it Keep It Uncensored Merry
Christmas and thank you to all our
viewers because without you we literally
don't have a show so thank you and we
appreciate it see you in the new
[Music]
year
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit her's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella scon
I rather like David Cameron I don't sort
of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rockets attached to itly the
tone has shifted in terms of what rashak
has done the question now is what he
does next the police are pro Palestine
that is just not right you swear an o in
the police to act without fear or favor
the co inquiry seems to have turned into
a sort of pantomim there's not really
any substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for Sadi Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the amount of time it's taken the
number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in about three years hundreds and
hundreds of mice in a box which he
walked into a branch of McDonald MC mous
man MC mous man MC mous man he should be
easy enough to catch this guy shouldn't
he I mean he's got house for of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film